what was that i said in the break room
review of defy bloods
if delroy lindo does not get an oscar
nomination
for his work in this then we need to
just
burn the academy awards to the ground
because
ho holy crap
all right
shall we
[Music]
maybe not the academy award
nominations are out this was something i
didn't think i'd have
anything to say about because most of
the things that were being tipped for a
heck of a lot of nominations i hadn't
seen only thing that i actually have
seen is maharani's black bottom
review up in the break room if you care
about that
but um looking over the reviews are
actually more specifically looking at
the headline that the film with the most
nominations was mank kinda got me
thinking because mank was a movie
that when the trailer came out i was a
little bit interested in
and then the reviews started coming out
and sounded good
and then for my own curiosity because
i've gotten a little bit more cautious
about historically set films
particularly ones that appear to have
some kind of political element in them
i looked into how accurate was it and i
knew it wasn't going to be 100 accurate
these things never
are they're not they can't be and they
that's just the way it is but the nature
of the changes
honestly kind of made me go i'm sorry
what
i kind of lost interest now
in the interest of not having people
tell me that i'm a jackass for not
watching the movie before talking about
it and then using it as a leaping off
point to talk about
this whole sort of thing that i'm going
to be getting into today
i did go and watch mank and as a film
strictly speaking as a film
it's pretty good acting's good it does a
really good job of evoking visually the
time period that it
comes from it cherry-picks and mimics
certain elements of
citizen kane which it's about the
writing of the script for citizen kane
so that's
totally fitting it's a very well done
movie
so i get why it was nominated especially
given that it's a little bit of a
hollywood self back padding session in
some ways it's
self-critical in specific areas but
kind of selectively which is part of
what i'm going to be getting into
a little bit on that before i launch
too far into this let me explain where
i'm going and then i'll back up and
we'll talk about mankind i'll talk about
some of the other films that i feel like
are marks of this same kind of thing
what i'm going to be talking about here
is historical revisionism
and more specifically politically minded
historical revisionism
in terms and i don't just mean like
you're revising it to put forward your
own politics i'm actually going to be
touching incredibly
lightly on possible motives for the
reasons these things happen
because i can't know the minds of the
people who make these decisions
screenwriters producers directors i
can't read their minds and unless
they've spoken on the record of exactly
why they did something it's really not
my place to project
i will discuss those possibilities a
little bit down the line
but when i say politically minded i mean
alterations of the political beliefs of
the people
being depicted or in some cases
pretending that those things didn't
exist and minimizing them
so let me first uh as quickly as i can
because this is not meant to be
specifically about mank
but let me uh show my work on this a
little bit i've linked to an article
from slate
which did at least from what i found the
best compiling
of the major differences so
long story as short as i'm prepared to
make it herman menkowitz was a
screenwriter he was contracted to a
variety of studios over the years in
hollywood he was renowned for his wit
being a drunk and being a very prolific
gambler
he wrote the original script for
orson welles that then got made into
what is widely considered to be one of
the greatest films ever made
there is some dispute in the year since
exactly how much of it he wrote versus
how much of it orson welles wrote they
both
got an academy award for the screenplay
was the only academy award
that uh kane got and
this is ostensibly about
the writing of the movie but it's
kind of not because it weaves a very
strange
political angle to things now let's not
say that herman menkewicz was a
completely a political person we
actually know
a little bit about some of his personal
politics at least
and some of those even get acknowledged
in the films but even the
framing of that seems a little suspect
to me
so spoilers for mank where it ends up
ultimately going
is this idea that mankowitz got wrapped
up in and was ultimately
personally moved and motivated by the
failed gubernatorial candidacy
of upton sinclair who was a
writer and a social activist
socialist who was running
for uh governor of california he
actually secured the democratic
uh party nomination and because he was
considered very socially radical
by the uh measures of the time actually
probably still by
a fair number of measures uh even today
he
uh spurred on basically all of the big
money in hollywood
to amass against him trying to figure
out how to stop him
now that much is all absolutely true
and what is shown in mank is that upton
sinclair was
largely impacted by these
political advertisements that were
dressed up like newsreel
interviews about that basically looked
to
try to make it look like these are the
kind of people voting for upton sinclair
these are the kind of people who are
voting against him what does that say to
you very much playing to
anxieties about class and
financial security and race and those
were
fairly effective and in the film
the idea for those uh was hit upon by a
gentleman by the name of irving
thalberg who was an acquaintance of
mankind's based off an
offhanded comment that mankowitz made so
in a way menquits feels a little bit
responsible
megawoods was also friends with shelly
metcalfe
who directed those ad pieces and metcalf
had a
massive crisis of conscience after
the election it was clear that those
really helped secure
sinclair's loss and metcalf took his
life out of a combination of
shame and also having recently gotten a
parkinson's diagnosis and
being scared to death of what that would
mean and this
then spurred mankowitz to
really hold a grudge against the forces
that amassed against upton sinclair and
he felt cost his friend his life
the parts of that that are true the ads
did exist
irving thalberg did orchestrate that he
was an acquaintance of mankowitz
shelly metcalfe did not exist there was
a director
for those things guy by the name of
felix feist who
died decades later and
did not appear to have any kind of
issues of conscience around having made
those things at
all and there is absolutely nothing
to back up the idea that mank
was in support of upton sinclair was
moved by upton sinclair
and wrote kane as revenge
against william randolph hearst who was
you know the big newspaper magnate who
was the big
money behind most of the this move to
help ensure that sinclair didn't get
into office now those aren't the only
liberties the film takes
when it comes to the question of who
really wrote citizen kane it
picks a version that makes mankowitz
look as much like the sole author as
humanly possible whereas
most uh research into the matter makes
it look like he may have written the
first draft himself but
wells did do significant contributions
between then
and when it actually went to film so
those should not be discounted
and the truth is most likely agreed to
be somewhere in the middle
but the film you know favors mank's
version of events which
it's meant to be about him that's
honestly fair enough
but it was that whole angle this whole
instilling of a brand new there's no
evidence to support at all
theory of political motivation
behind the writing of the greatest film
ever made and
in addition that's not the only
political tweaking
uh mankowitz has a conversation with his
brother joseph who is a real
a real person and basically
uh about the what was at the time the
newly forming writers guild of america
which
was is the writers union in hollywood
and mank
didn't have any interest in joining he
didn't think it was a good idea he was
pretty outspoken against unions now in
the film
this is a private conversation between
him and his brother where he's
expressing like this is just not a good
idea
and those sentiments are very much
something that mankowitz
had in real life except in real life
he didn't have them in private
conversations he took out a full-page ad
in variety
saying join the writer's guild of
america all you have to lose is your
brains
so to take something that was an
outspoken
public position and turn it into a
private conversation
immediately downplays how strongly he
held these beliefs
and then putting that early and having
him appear to be inspired by upton
sinclair later
implied a backing off of those beliefs
which again there is nothing in evidence
of
now i want to move off of mank as a
specific
thing because i feel like
there's an odd trend in terms of
either shifting or minimizing the
politics of people
in biographical and or historically set
pictures
some other examples from recent years
you have something like the greatest
showman which basically
took the most generous
interpretation of views that at
various points in his life pt barnum did
express
assumed that they were all true at face
value and assumed that he held those
beliefs
all through his life as opposed to maybe
this was something he came to much later
than the point when he was
basically running a human zoo there's
the iron lady
the meryl streep film which
despite being about margaret thatcher
one of
the most influential conservative
figures in world history from the last
40 years
and did a biographical pick about her
that avoided her
actual political stances actions and
beliefs as much as
humanly possible i'm sorry what
and part of what's frustrating for me
about
this is that i as i mentioned
the reviews that came out about bank
were great but i only saw a passing
mention
of historical inaccuracies in a couple
of them
usually only fixating on the fact that
it kind of demonizes wells and favors
make in the authorship question
but nearly everything completely omitted
all the other stuff now i don't know if
this was because the reviews in question
didn't know what the real history was
it's not actually particularly well
known history and unless they did
additional research
they may not have known the things about
sinclair or the fact that showing
metcalf was made up etc so
that's a possibility or they feel that
it doesn't detract from the experience
of watching it as a film but it's just
strange to me
that it's so well reviewed so well
regarded
yet can have such a clear
and drastic shift and or
insertion of political positions into it
but not enough to warrant even a mention
on the wikipedia page and the wikipedia
page
saw fit to mention every single music
track and how long they are
but wouldn't even give a passing mention
to the historical elements of this it's
very strange to me and it seems to be
this notion or this
trend from filmmakers writers producers
what have you
of altering or minimizing the political
stances of the people they choose to
depict
now at its most extreme
and comical you get something like
the patriot
the mel brooks movie from 2000 which i
actually rather like
i think it's a good movie but it is
laughable
the fact that this takes place during
the american revolution
and mel brooks's character owns a farm
at a place
i'm not sure plantation might be the
wrong word because i i cannot remember
enough but he has black people work in
the fields
but the film chose to firmly establish
oh these aren't slaves these are freed
people who he employs
the reality is is that people with that
kind of money and power
in that point of time had slaves
they just did we know they did it's not
necessarily a comfortable fact but
pretending that oh no no no mel gibson
isn't playing an actual historical
figure on that so it's more a matter of
historical setting
um rather than trying to make a specific
actual real-life person look better
but it was so bizarre and frankly just
lava
it became a joke like why would you do
that
now i said i wouldn't dwell too much on
motives because i can't know
motives but i can surmise a couple of
possibilities
and then regardless of what the actual
um
inclinations are for why this happens
there's still a problem and i'll get to
that
the first possibility is that the people
who are making these decisions
which again it's multitudinous how many
people
would be involved in these kind of
decisions from screenwriters to
directors probably producers and
possibly even actors if they are a big
enough name or they're the kind of
person who gets an executive producer
credit just for being in a movie
all these people are going to have some
degree of influence but at some level
part of it might be a
desire to make a character more palpable
to the movie-going audience so the idea
of doing it from the audience's sake is
you want the audience to be
on the side of your protagonist and
there's an inclination to not
give them an element to their
personality that would be considered
irredeemable by modern day standards
and especially if you're going to do a
historical drama of anyone who had any
degree of influence you are going to run
into
people who were racist sexist
misogynists
antisemitic so your options become
well let's just not talk about that
or in more extreme cases a bit like mank
let's project a different set
of beliefs or beliefs that we can't
actually back up that this person
actually held
and i don't i mean there's always the
possibility that there is
you know a political agenda to try and
alter people the public's perception of
someone and i'm not gonna discount that
and say it's
impossible but that's the kind of
conspiratorial narrative i really go out
of my way to try to avoid
i don't wanna i don't wanna spew it i
don't wanna have it in my comments
i don't wanna go there unless you've got
evidence to back it up just please don't
i wonder if part of it comes from an
instinct that we like to believe
that we only relate to and
connect with good
people or people who hold the values
that we
consider to be good
and it can be difficult
if you have created something a bit more
like a
hero narrative in your head
coming to terms with how this person
doesn't
meet you where you're at
in terms of your own beliefs and values
can be difficult
i mean i've had to make my own call on
that with
figures like jk rowling which obviously
that's a different conversation because
mankowitz has been
dead for a very long time so it's not
quite the same thing of dealing with
someone who's still alive and you have
to cope with it
then but i think there is an
instinct to be like well
i want to give this person a motivation
that would be the kind of motivation
that
i would have had or that i could have
admired
because we don't really know why
mankowitz wrote a script that very
clearly skewered
william randolph hearst we don't
actually know how much of that was his
own idea and how much of that was
spurred on by orson welles who
while it is very likely that mankowitz
wrote the complete original first draft
more or less on his own
uh wells was in contact with him prior
to that knocking back and forth story
concepts
so even if we take it for granted that
it was mankowitz's decision to target
hearst and have him be the basis for
charles foster kane
the man as a personality so best as
history remembers him
just liked needling people he was a
little bit of an intellectual troll
which is something the uh the film
actually does kind of capture but it
still felt the need to give him
a motivation a grudge
for some reason this sort of thing
troubles me in general
because it feels like a microcosm
for this country and this culture's
inability to grapple with its own
faults in modern day and in
history we don't like
being reminded that the founding fathers
were slave owners
or if someone's gonna remind it we want
to brush that off and instead focus on
everything else they did
because we can't seem to
help but sort the world into the good
people
and the bad people
and when we've decided someone is
a good person is one of the good people
we don't want to believe the things that
in a vacuum we would go well that's a
bad thing that bad people do
i had a comment actually earlier today
at time of filming
on my video that i did about joss whedon
i'm not going to
put it up because i don't want to do a
direct call out on them but
they said things like he's a good person
he deserves a shot at redemption and all
these other things
and very clearly this commenter wasn't
able to grapple with the idea that
something that they
liked was made by anyone other than
a good person and i know
some people feel like either they feel
themselves or they feel like society is
telling them
if you think someone is a bad person you
are not allowed to enjoy their art
and look i say that as someone who
has very strongly distanced myself from
the works of jk rowling
at this point as well as kevin spacey
kevin spacey was in some of my favorite
movies of all time none of which i've
rewatched
but it's not a spite it's because i'm
not comfortable with it
but i'm not suddenly gonna turn around
and do what
some people tend to do and again you've
seen this with jk rowling if you pay
attention to the conversation
one of the defense mechanisms that
people go to
even former fans well the books weren't
actually all that good in the first
place
basically removing the value of the
books so that it's okay
to file the entire thing under well bad
people
but if the book has value and the writer
is a freaking nightmare
trying to meld all that together and
work both those sides through your head
that's work
and people don't want to do the work
it's like when i talked about how you
can't separate the artist from the art
why that phrase frustrates me because
people use it as an excuse to not
do the work of reconciling these things
and i think
as a nation as a culture this is a
sickness
we won't find a way to acknowledge
that people we admire or people who did
one or two things we admire or stood for
something we that we admire
had other big problems with them
we minimize those we ignore them or we
rewrite them
and is it any wonder
that we live in a nation that can't seem
to reconcile
its own history and acknowledge
the bad things that we as a country have
done
because we're a good country
who does good things
and acknowledging the bad things
feels like you're saying the country's
bad and in fact
there are people out there who make that
argument that if you say
something is bad about this
you are condemning everything
people say that about artistic works
that if i
say jk rowling
is a turf and a transphobe
that i'm saying her work has no value
i'm not saying that
or that if i'm saying her work has value
that i have to
not complain about her i absolutely do
have to complain about her
but whether it is something as extreme
as the patriot and pretending like
somebody adjacent to the founding
fathers wouldn't have had slaves
or something as selective as the
greatest showman
and it and look there are things that
mitigate this
the greatest showman for example being a
big overblown musical
one can make the argument well who's
going to take it as a historical
document they're busting out into song
for crying out loud
okay there's an argument to be made
there
but a lot of people for a lot of these
figures
come to know them first if not
exclusively through
film and i'm not saying that
we have to dirty up these figures
like when i talk about tropes like when
i talk about trends
it's not each individual instance that
bothers me
i could have written mank off and these
issues that that
uh of historical revisionism if i didn't
take a step back
and look at the tendencies of
hollywood to do this in general
and some might even say well holly in
hollywood in a movie like mank is
self-critical as well i mean look at how
it portrays louie b mayer
who is a studio head and not a good
person
and it's absolutely condemning him yeah
but it's condemning him because he was
associated with hearst
and hearst has become one of the
acceptable villains of history
so yeah it's okay to condemn him he's
already dirtied
by association mank isn't
so let's make him more heroic let's
let's say flat out
that he was the only person at the
studio
who tried to fight back and refused to
contribute to a political campaign when
louis b mayer said everybody had to do
it
when in fact there were a collection of
people at the studio
who refused to do it and mank was not
one of them people
can be admirable they can be fascinating
they can be intriguing they can be worth
talking about
without being overly heroic
i think about the review i did for the
straight story
which might become my new benchmark
for a true story or biographical film
because what was great about that film
is the fact that it
is so accurate
both logistically but also emotionally
the tone it doesn't amp things up
that's a movie about a guy who rides
several hundred miles on a riding mower
to go and see his brother
and it could have upped a ton of stuff
could have added a ton more
complications
about things that happened to him on the
road or a bunch of more things you know
overblown
uh the motivations for certain things
that happened it didn't do any of that
because the story was still worth
telling
as it actually happened
you don't have to make the story more
exaggerated
you don't have to make the character
more noble
complicated people are worth
telling stories about
and we seem to be okay with that in
fiction
way more than we are in biopics and that
just troubles me as a pattern
as a trend and again
specific instances some you can justify
better than others or some you can brush
off
more than others but to see something
like mank get this many nominations this
must praise
this high uh rotten tomatoes score i
actually did check first time i've been
on that site in
a year but despite all that
so little virtually no conversation
about this nonsensical conspiratorial
motivation for
what he did and this complete
fabrication
of his involvement in politics that
there's no evidence he was involved with
and what we know doesn't exactly line up
with those political views
the casualness i think is what bothers
me
the casualness and the failure for these
things to get
noted the failure for them to get
explained but in interviews david
fincher would be asked about
the authorship issue
but not the rest of it not that i could
find but again that
i have some frustration without about
not knowing the motivations but even
without motivations
how casually this is happening
how frequently and how little it's
called out
it just irks me this was not a scripted
video
if i'd had more time i would have sat
down and really structured my thoughts a
bit more cleanly on this whole thing but
i got to be completely honest
i am behind the eight ball on a fair
number of things right now
and i've also got my birthday coming up
this weekend and i really just
wanted a clean plate i want
i wanted to be sure everything was done
so i i
was not prepared to have this eat up
more time
despite how long i ended up rambling
uh i i hope folks will restrain from
saying well it's the woke agenda
because again we don't know motivations
and it's a completely different
motivation if they are
changing things because of a presumed
favoritism from the audience or doing
things because of their own values and
unless you can prove
and provide evidence of some kind that
one or the other is the case then
i that's not an that's not an argument
that is going to
benefit anybody but i will still be
happy to hear your thoughts
you leave them down in the comments i
have a patreon
that's how i make my living mention it's
my birthday that be a nice present i
also have a
amazon and etsy wish list i mean it
won't go for that
um but you don't have to do any of that
liking sharing subscribing helps me out
too but don't worry about that either
because at the end of the day you are
the council
i'm only running the meetings and until
next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]